reports of shots fired caused chaos at
lovers and friends last night that
situation did turn out to be a false
alarm but three people were hurt when
crowns rushed out of the festival
grounds madison kimbrough joins us live
near sahara and las vegas boulevard
tonight with more madison
authorities say a report of gunfire was
heard right here as you can see behind
me at 10 pm on festival grounds the
festival initially posted this sign you
see here just after 10 p.m that read
attention we have a security incident at
the festival authorities are
investigating this of course sent
concert goers into a frenzy with large
groups of people rushing to leave the
venue after an investigation took place
metro police confirmed that there was no
evidence of a shooting people we spoke
to say the scare and the heat made for a
chaotic night
i was terrified yeah we saw tlc and we
sat down for a minute in between usher
was going to come on so i saw lights
coming on my girlfriend was sitting
behind me i looked back at her and then
all i know is the crowd just
completely
pushed forward i got trampled
like everybody wouldn't know what was
going on
police say the three people hurt had
minor injuries and were taken to the
hospital you're taking a live look now
at festival grounds the lovers and
friends music festival featuring artists
like usher tlc and ludacris is set to
conclude tonight